in the chinese system we probably have i
can at least show three evidences
to show that the chinese
know about the flood we have a word for
boat
and
you have eight people in a boat
that's the character that's the
character oh wow for boat
and so you're wondering why
we oftentimes look at the bible through
western eyes here in america but is
there anything in the east that can help
substantiate the claims of the bible
from
culture and history
find out on this episode of led live
[Music]
light exposing darkness welcome everyone
to another episode of led live
it's so glad to have you here with us
today and we have another special guest
on our show a guest that really sprang
from a conversation one morning i
remember i came into the office and i
was talking about a a sermon that i had
been listening to and the presenter was
a neil canda and he was talking about
how
different cultures have these elements
of
biblical heritage and biblical history
and and culture and i was just like wow
this is amazing and one of those was the
chinese culture
so
i was talking about it in the office and
michael who's not on camera he's always
behind the camera hi michael
he um he told us you know i just heard
something like this there was a pastor
who came to our church and presented
this very thing and so we asked him well
can you invite him or see if he's
available to be on our show and lo and
behold we have dr wang with us here this
morning this is dr samuel wang
and he
specializes in missions but he's done a
lot of
research on chinese culture and history
especially as it relates to
biblical history and biblical knowledge
so this is going to be i think a very
exciting and enlightening show
that you're going to help us with today
so welcome thank you
all right so
how is it
i mean have you always been a christian
was this something that always
interested in you or
i mean have you come from a different
background than that you know i was born
in china born and raised up in china and
when communism was
at its full force at the time
i came to
christianity when i turned into 30 years
old okay wow okay now i i've heard
stories of christians in china like
churches that would meet in their
basements
and they would have to bring one person
in at a time and sometimes it would take
hours to get the whole church body in
the room was it kind of like that
at a time when religion was not allowed
there was about 30 years
and from the 1950s to all the way to the
80s
any religion including christianity was
not allowed so
out of those days when you tried to have
a meeting
it was very
sacred
what would happen if you got caught
i mean you you wouldn't be put into at
least to be detained
or put into prison
so if you're a repeat offender
then you might get into more severe
trouble like long-term jail or even
exactly many people get arrested because
of that wow wow we yeah that's very
similar to what happens in like russia
and and those kinds of places same thing
anywhere communism has been same kind of
thing you know it's always you know they
did everything in secret they get
arrested some people end up in jail for
a long time
but the gospel is powerful i mean it
really makes you like uh
like think about how luxuriously we have
it here you know what i mean like you
listen to these stories of what other
people do just to go to church and then
you talk to young people today and it's
like i don't want to go to church today
and other people in the other parts of
the world are risking their lives for
this i i met a pastor in texas and i
think he was from the ukraine
and he kind of grew up a little bit old
school and he says he remembers when his
brother and sister went to go be
baptized they had to go before the
church board
and they grilled them wow on their
beliefs you know it's like if you're
gonna claim this you better know it you
better believe it and you better be
serious about it it was like a very
solemn serious thing it wasn't like oh
yeah great we're gonna dunk you in the
tank yeah yeah i i guess a question
right off the bat is you know
china was always
in my mind buddhist but maybe that's not
the case
well buddhist came to china about 2 000
years ago
a little less than that so it was uh
introduced much later the chinese
history is longer yeah and so if i have
a chart here actually
if we look at this chart
and compare that with the biblical
chronology you can see creation
it happened at 404 bc
and that's how
we have our calendar is based upon that
date
and so you have a 27 when jesus was 30
years old he was baptized 31 a.d he
you know he was crucified and ascended
to heaven
that all dated from that date 4004 bc
okay
now if you go from there and then uh
at the two three four eight bc then you
have the tile and the flood that's 1656
years later
and then 101 years later you have the
tower of babel now before all of this
time the world had that one language
was it chinese providentially is the
language in heaven gonna be chinese
we we're not quite sure about what
language that was
now i want to just show you that the
beginning of the chinese it was just 42
years after the town of babel
then we had our
first dynasty that was about four
thousand two hundred years ago so
roughly before buddhism come in
we had another
2200 of chinese history
42 years from the flood or no from the
tower okay so two years ago do you have
written records that go back that far
oh yes yes
that's great the chinese
um you know today basically we have five
ancient writing systems in the world
okay
and like uh samaritan sumerian and the
egyptian and the maya iran and uh greek
i mean
anyway i forgot the other one but
chinese is one of them chinese is also
the only one i think one is babylon the
only one that survived
until today this is the only one right
all the other ancient writing systems
were gone so if you're asking for any
ancient record
and he the first one probably is not the
jewish
the oldest the ancient one is the
chinese
wow
so i have a question about the flood um
so
are the chinese like oh like they all
talk about there was a flood a worldwide
flood that's part of your history well
in the chinese system we probably have i
can at least show three evidences
to show that the chinese
know about the flood they are the
descendants of noah's family
and number one is that
we
we have a word for boats
and
you have eight people in a boat
that's the character that's the
character oh wow for boat
boat
okay boat
this is a chinese character
both in a modern writing system
it has only three parts
let's look at these three parts three
parts
one by one the first part
is a vessel is a vessel on the water
basically it means
boat already this means
the boat
the second part el middle part middle
part
means eight
is eight
one two three four five six seven eight
the third part means month
month
in in chinese in in chinese language
mandarin or you can say mandarin
month
normally represent a person like one
month means one person two months means
two persons remember there's eight
people
were in the ark with the flood when the
rain
came
and so you're wondering why yeah yeah no
today if you run into any if you have
been to any chinese restaurant or
whatever you check on their phone number
normally ended with eight
interesting and the chinese likes the
lucky number of eight you want a why
because
all the lucky ones to survive because
noah's family have eight people the
whole world come from there
i think
in their mind the number eight is a
lucky number
so the number eight is very special now
this is number one there is one more
that would
you cannot defeat that
the bible said you know
if lucky normally you live like 70 years
and if you are strong you can go to 80
90. my mother passed away this year she
was 96.
and
i'm sorry
but
but the chinese say no you are supposed
to live 120 years
where did that come from yeah that's
what it was shortened too
that was a the only time that was given
in the bible is in genesis chapter 6
verse 13
you know the world was wild god said i
will still give you 120 years
and that is recorded
kept in the chinese so the chinese think
the the lifespan was 120 it should be
but later it got this you know we got it
deteriorated and now it's getting
shorter it always seems like the longest
living people though come from china
like when you see the 110 1112 and
they're they like seem like they're
always from
asian culture
yeah there is a book like china studies
is produced by uh
yeah dr campbell and it's talking about
they follow different lifestyles and
they conclude
the chinese lifestyle is the one that is
more healthy
it's probably it can be helpful i guess
okay so you have writings that go back
long periods of time
but if you have writings that go back so
far
why is it that
chinese people aren't necessarily aware
of all these things today or even
americans or anybody else like
why is this
if you have it written down and you have
it you know in history why is it so hard
to find where was the departure yeah
well
you know the
when you talk about history like china
india
these people have a long history
and you have to study for many years to
finish you know it's not like you go to
an american school
third grade you finish it
um
however the
the there is a change
that change let me just make it very
short the change happened in
when the
british came
trying to sell their opinions
to china
and they defeated china and this you
know china from then on trying to start
thinking what went wrong i mean
they came with the gunpowder with guns
but the gunpowder were invented
by our ancestors we use it peacefully
but when it went to west is for war
and now we were getting even defeated by
these guys
and so they're trying to
to find the reason how can we
become strong and not to be bullied
by these
these people
and from then on they say oh we have to
learn from them
we learn from them the way then we can
defeat them so they send people come to
the west to learn that's where the
turning point starts
the very first thing that was introduced
to china
was evolution
survival of the fist 1840 1840 around
that kind of timeline and starting from
there later on you have a communism one
after another atheism all of this were
introduced
in the last 140 80 some years and that
changed
not only the chinese thinking but also
how the world looking at china so the
previous traditions were kind of
forgotten we started to adopt
so-called
you know new culture and new knowledge
and
that is that was a turning point
wow
okay
so
what more can you share with us about
these things from the past
uh but even though there was a turning
point however you every culture you
still got tradition
like i mentioned earlier we've got the
chinese writings
it still remains the same 4 000 years
old now we got the bible here the bible
is only 3500 years old
so anything we have put in writing
was older
than the hebrew bible in other words if
we find anything from the chinese
culture
we did not copy that from the hebrews
we had it
prior to the hebrews
now we have
the chinese characters i can show you
of just from the character itself
that the eden story was recorded over
there
are you ready for some of those yeah
yeah i want to see this yeah
let's just simply you look at
you know
a word um
[Music]
for talking about heaven okay okay and a
heaven is you have
one stroke there
and then
then you have a man
so in other words a man is a patent
after
after the one above is as a
a man from above that's heaven so we we
have a man which is written similar
um
like heaven so
even for that word alone that you can
see that's uh this is uh
how
man come from we come from with patent
after
heaven oh wow and um
so so this top yeah this is the man
that's heaven yeah this is this this is
top from above yeah and then this is of
course is a man yeah and once you put
these two together
then you have
the man from above
right he is heaven now how to write man
and then the lower part is just how we
write a man so in a way you can see when
the bible said a man was made in the
image of god and then you can see in the
chinese writings
the ancestor
they they were so clever they just coded
in such a way that you can still see it
even today
we see that
i i think it's really neat that you guys
have this language that is not only a
visual representation but it's like
you're reading it as well you know what
i mean like it's like i'm a picture
person like i learned from from that but
i just think that's neat that your
characters tell a story as well as you
know it's your you know the chinese uh
we call this tien this is a chinese way
of saying
to me i think i couldn't find any better
theology
than the chinese theology let me explain
that to you
in in tien and this is the the name for
the creator okay and then how do you say
what is the most important in life
and i would still say that's tien
and that's the most important thing how
about space
skies and universe
because you come from tien you come from
heaven so we say still say tien we still
use that because there's no other better
measurement so so if you said i'm going
in a rocket ship to outer space
yes oh that's interesting and and then
not only that
each day you you have a day each day
what is the measurement for our day in
english you have a date no for the
chinese you have a tien
you have heaven
as a measurement of the time that you
receive each day so here you have
you have not only god as creator you
have him as the most important you have
the space you live from him the time
that you live is also from him
and for
that is exactly what genesis 1 1 says
the in english and also in chinese we we
missed
all the english translation missed the
one part in genesis 1 1.
mr iv the fourth letter in
the hebrew that is basically talking
about
god is beginning at the end he's talking
relating not only god created heaven and
earth but he is also the beginning
and the end that part is lost but
however that is all contained in this
one word tian in the chinese so i think
it's really neat that in in english we
you know we we say that god is the i am
right well in hebrew i guess he said
that as well but um you know you could
just complete that sentence with
whatever god is your everything i am
your provider i am your god i am you
know so yeah it's kind of neat that same
sort of thing translates into chinese as
well
yes uh the chinese you know the all the
bible story in genesis in the beginning
happened in the garden of eden
and so the chinese
retained the garden of eden we have a
character
you know like this one um here and you
can see
in the character in the garden you have
trees i mean this
chinese original chinese is very
pictographic you can see a tree and of
course
then how about garden
how about they eat them now eden you
have the bible said eating you have four
rivers
flowing out of it now today we have seen
many pictures and eden is flat that is
not very good eden is a high mountain
the highest the biggest waterfalls
coming from eden because the water
flowing out of eden you're gonna form
four big rivers
if you're gonna become four big rivers
and it must be from a high place and in
the revelation it says it's a square
but you look at the chinese character
for eden for garden or eden
and in the middle you can see there's
four rivers going and flowing
yeah so so this this shows the
the earliest chinese they were you know
before the bible was written
human being has lived for 2500 years
now how do they know the revelation of
god
of course by word of mouth
and ancient cultures like india
like chinese
they were exposed to the oral version
and
they preserve especially the chinese
they preserve it
the oral revelation of god
in their writings in the tradition
and also in the classics and a little i
will share a little more but let me uh
maybe i share you
just some stories
you know you have
god told them was one restriction you
don't touch that
tree
and in this world you can see a tree in
the middle right
and then you have a mouse
god said the only thing you need to
restrain yourself
is that your mouth will not touch from
that tree wow that is the word for
restraint wow how how else can you right
explain that
that's amazing that you're not supposed
to eat something i mean that yeah from a
tree yeah that's interesting and uh
however the what this is a meaning woman
she came to these two trees
now
the did the chinese love it know that
she actually she was
uh she was facing the tree of
uh knowledge and good and evil
her back was against the tree of life so
she was facing this way wow
because the bible actually didn't say
that clearly but
you really you know when they were
expelled from the garden of eden the
last one they they saw was the tree of
life
on their way out
so evidently
they were eating from this tray of
knowledge and good and evil then god
expel that so they come out from there
so
that was this is the chinese word for
greed
for covet
i mean who yeah right where where did
you get that the first time the first
thing who first
person
have the covet
it was under the trip yeah there'd be no
reason to tell it that way
unless you have the prior history and
the knowledge and god also showed to
them
if you
you know if you eat of that
you will die
and so you see a tree there
and you see two the hands
and then two mouths
so you can see these two people eat from
the street this is a chinese word for to
die why
did they have to die
it's really incredible it is incredible
i mean do the chinese like do they talk
about this or recognize it or is it just
you've written it so many times
you know you gotta you know you take it
for granted i think i i see something
interesting
whatever is the most precious thing in
your culture that's the thing you lose
for instance
for the jewish they were looking for
messiah yeah it was written in it was
written alphabet their language is their
money it's the dirt
you name it their whole economy when
messiah came lost
wow they got the gps but they couldn't
find it i mean
i think it's the same thing with the
chinese it was there
but somehow
we
we lost it we
uh we didn't completely lose it but
still we
we just lost majority so so so i guess
how how did it get like so
shifted away from it's like
you know it's like satan is always there
to blind the eyes of men right he's
always trying to hide what god is trying
to reveal in plain sight and it's like
what is what is the last book of the
bible called it's called revelation and
what is it revealing jesus christ you
know what is god always trying to do
with his people he's trying to cover
them satan's always like trying to take
you know stuff oh i mean this is just
the war right now
yeah let me just show you this is
probably the last one i can share about
the characters
god does not stop there
okay you know this the chinese not only
know what had happened
yeah the the sad story of the fall we
have many of those but for the time's
sake we just show it's just a sample but
the chinese also know the plan of
salvation
and if they depict it like in this word
you have a fallen disobedient man and
obviously he's falling so he's upside
down he's upside down okay and then you
have another man
a noble man
standing straight
so this uh noble man come to
help
to save the following man
from being falling further
and that is unexpected yeah
that word is unexpected blessing
the chinese word it's unexpected plus
you are supposed to die hey but because
of that standing obedient and noble man
you're not going to die wow and in that
one word you can see that there's the
gospel
complete plan of salvation
wow yeah this is also this word have
several meanings is also rejoice because
you
you are saved from
being dead and now of course you give
thanks
this is also the word for happiness
oh wow unexpected grace
and all contained in one word so
i mean as a chinese i said it's really
fortunate to know the chinese because we
can see some extra biblical evidence
to give full support
of the hebrew bible so this being
chinese history how do the chinese react
to it because i'm sure some christians i
know it has to be done in a delicate way
but
is this used to
bring
chinese people to christ and are they
receptive to it yes um
you know the last year was kodan
you know
covet and i was locked down in the house
i couldn't do anything i started to
share some i
make a one minute video i can share
some of these things i did have one
minute one video the highest
uh within two months it's about 400 000
viewers
wow and i did about 30 of them average
about 200 thousand viewers wow
and praise god yeah we're hungry well
you have two billion people
but i i only did it in a wechat group i
mean this is just one of the platforms
that you can you can see when the
chinese see
it's there when you tell them oh yeah i
never noticed that
they just uh embrace it wow it's like
something right under your nose yeah
yeah but but i think what a neat thing
to do is is you know to really take
something that they're familiar with and
to just expand their opening of
understanding a little bit more you know
it's like
it's a really great way to reach them
wow that's really super neat if this is
uh you know it's more literal and many
people just ah i don't get it but there
are also traditions there are also
historical sites which are still there
today okay which shows the 4 000 years
worship
now the one that you see
on the screen here
the chinese is called the descendant of
yan and the huang
yen i would say hiv is shame
because uh his name in the chinese uh
chandong shen
uh fanatically very similar we have
three names recorded we have noah we
have shame we have javas the three names
in the chinese fushi these three names
were recorded but we didn't record a han
because han
was the cursed one it's uh it's a black
ship and he's yeah
and the chinese emphasized respecting
parents and
there's no other culture in the world
expand the fifth commandment
to
sixteen thousand words
sixteen thousand words the fifth the
first commandment so the fifth
commandment is on your father and your
mother that your days make the children
expanded
to such a
vast field it it goes to
not only human parents
it goes to
the your creator you are leaders you are
officials and you are elderly
that's why there's so much respect and
uh if
even in the family if you you know like
your first uh
son and a first daughter
they normally
raise help raise the younger younger
ones so this respect goes you know just
extend it's not simply parents the
connotation
sixteen thousand words i don't see any
other culture have this kind of
understanding
so do you think the longevity i mean we
mentioned that you know it seems to be
that the
asian culture lives longer than the rest
of us
with a blessing like that attached to it
god's word is
what he said that's what he do if you
honor and do his way and he will honor
right yeah so the huangdi is another one
that would consider to be our ancestor
and he was about four thousand years ago
as a legendary king
and this to some of our viewers may not
be so uh familiar but however you can
see
these different places this is where the
chinese
worship have it
and even today we still have you can go
to that site this is a
this one many people have heard is the
ching shin hongdi
is an emperor qing who was the one who
connected the great wall okay we are 20
200 years ago just about 200 years
before christ he was the one and he also
dedicated that place as a place to
worship heaven
and chinese and when you mean heaven not
necessarily just the environment but
like god no oh god oh god yeah
yeah they they know they say uh they say
you know before when the world when god
in the beginning there was all darkness
and void and darkness and then god came
a separate darkness and from light and
the five elements start to
play in place and then you have heaven
and the earth you have
everything you have a man and then woman
the order as recorded in the chinese
is the same as recorded in the hebrew
bible only that the chinese recorded
about five to seven hundred years
earlier
so for those who are questioning and
even thinking the bible is a western
culture come on yeah it's
yeah okay
seriously well well you know the wise
men coming to
seek out jesus had something that they
were reading right
i mean
you know they came wait i don't know we
typically they came from asia
i can tell you that in the chinese the
first chinese dictionary
it was in a 100 years 100 a.d
and it says the word about this uh our
family name
is the born of a woman and then
interpretation of that is
uh
a woman a mother of antiquity
conceived by heaven give birth to a son
he is called the son of heaven
and this predates jesus
the record in that dictionary is 100
years after jesus however
that was predates jesus right that that
prophecy that explanation of that word
and we have many people know how to say
nihao
in chinese
and the word hao means good
what is how is the seed of the woman
really the seed of the woman the only
hope for humanity
and he is the one who bring whenever we
say niha we're saying the seed of the
woman bring blessing to you
it's a little more than to say good
morning you're saying that yeah the seed
of the woman so
the chinese have a lot of about this i'm
showing you these elders other places to
worship
heaven this is in xi'an and many people
know this one
beijing
the temple beijing this was built 600
years ago wow and this is a once a year
service in chinese history
we have a daily service morning and
evening which is done in the family
so the
mother the father normally is the one
who
worship in the morning and the evening
of his incense
you know sometimes we just connect
incense with what with buddhists
what does that incense represent in
chinese culture
i mean i know what it represents in the
hebrew culture but what does it
represent
it's a good question you know the
culturally things the meaning keep on
changing but instance in basically in
the chinese means life
my my lifetime my descendant
i am bringing my descendant you have
blessed me with the descendant so i'm
coming to worship you
that's basically what it is so when that
instance stopped means this family
no more descendant so it doesn't come
the family wouldn't come to
offer instances anymore
so instance is the way
our life is also short just like
instance you're burning it's gone
and you need to make the best use of it
to give thanks to the one who gives your
life that's why they bring incense
that's the way to
worship heaven i know it's similar in
the revelation we make our
prayers and always like incense now this
temple is also there in china but if you
notice it there's nothing
no images
for
once a year the the emperor will come
and they look at the structure you know
the three layers similar like the
sanctuary i mean it doesn't look the
same but it's you have the altar
but hey you compare the hebrews with the
chinese israel with the chinese
israel they were taken out of egypt
and for three months
god gave them manna
brought them to mount sinai
and then moses went up
only 40 days
they didn't see moses right then they
start to do what
yeah party training party
go to cove yeah yeah golden calf and
just start having imaging yeah watch it
but the chinese didn't see anything
either
the chinese didn't see any images for 4
000 years until 1911.
no idols
1911 with the boxing rebellion the
republic of china was formed okay so
there's no more empress
there's no emperors therefore
at that time they associate the temple
worship
as a privilege of the emperor so when
they did done away with the emperor so
they also done away with this
temple worship
but also sing my son who was the founder
of the republic of china he was a
christian
i am not sure what he know
maybe is because he also know that
christ is the sacrifice
so the emperor
was acting not just as a civil authority
but as a priestly authority right it's
just like high priest that's interesting
did they call themselves christians
no they no no question even in the bible
you don't call yourself christians true
the name christian was given by the
gentiles to those who follow god antioch
yeah
so what did the chinese call themselves
was there a name or just a way of life
they just simply call them the son of
god okay and just like the children of
god
you're the sons of god
so we've talked about chinese language
and landmarks but what about the names
because in hebrew in hebrew a lot of the
names have attributes of god so is that
the same in the chinese culture very
much so the chinese name every name has
meaning it's not only have a sound you
need to have a good sound and
good writing and also good with good
meaning because we like parents we give
a name to our children and for life
that's the time they were going to be
called
and that concept the value system that
aspiration aspiration in that name needs
to motivate that person for life
and like for my my name is
and this is taken from an ancient
chinese poem it means
worshiping heaven with trembling heart
and spirit that's amazing i wish more
people like like understood the the
names and what they mean
did you name your kids with meaning
no
no no i guess culture are different
my mom took that very very seriously she
actually bought like african books and
the names and their meanings she went
through it that's how i got candy the
loved one she just wanted
for my name to have some kind of
significance and that's true in a lot of
african countries like it
has to have some kind of significance
because they know the power of a name
you're calling that all the time i mean
think of the bible how we
call or in a sense invoke
the specific name of god to help us in
that time and it's the same with us
today that's why i think it's funny that
like you know um isaac would call jacob
the deceiver i mean it's like you know
you're just like oh you're a little
cheater
you know like i don't know it just seems
funny because as a as a parent and you
see that newborn baby it's like you just
want them to thrive in life and why
wouldn't you
name that it's interesting where do you
think um the misconception comes from is
it a misconception i don't know but the
the worldwide view that christianity
started in western culture where do you
think that came from well in
in the bible we know jesus was crucified
by
romans
and the christianity went into 300 years
canonization they were kind of romanized
and so
what
i'll give you one comparison you can see
you look at the jesus teaching
beatitudes
we have to use every single one
it have to do with either your behavior
or your being
blessed are those who are poor in spirit
you know blessed as a peacemaker your
peacemaker is how you should behave
like
poor in spirit is your character it's
your state
however when it's
when it's moved to the analyzed
tendency this way and then you have the
apostles creed
you have all the creed
and every single one is just you just
needs to have intellectual consent has
nothing to do with your being
or your behavior
so a practical a
life living christianity
all of a sudden become intellectual
exercise
and
before you know god is to do his
commandment
like
the beauty of the soul
is a harmony and obedience to the word
of god that was the true beauty of the
soul but that is the way it also shows
the true knowledge
of god but then it will come to greek
way of christianity you start to talk
about the attributes of god you start to
talk about trinity
i mean this is so greek
to know god is not to know what his
trinity or not is to know him in your
life in your practice
you'll be or you're doing but
the christianity now what we learn you
know we every church is busy to produce
a set of beliefs it's so greek and not
hebrew and said
we are trying to defend some doctrines
which is
you look at it from the greek
perspective
i mean like paul said you know circums
circumcision is nothing uncircumcision
is nothing some of these things
is not so important
what is important is like what solomon
said
you know fear god and keep his
commandment
and that is
whole duty as a calling that for us so i
would say
the the tendencies is uh that
we have some
is the greek influence
on the upon the
very christianity
so you said you're going to go into some
prophecy
well you know we we talk about the
chinese characters if if that's in the
chinese writings about the oral version
of god
if also the the tradition of worshiping
god they call that the border sacrifice
you have to worship
bring the sacrifice outside of the
capital
and of course you see that is a
fulfillment of jesus
because jesus was offered outside of the
city
outside of jerusalem right so if you
look at hebrew chapter 13 you have to
walk
out of the gate
it's a border sacrifice he was the
border sacrifice is not offered within
the city
so that is always there in the chinese
and for for all of us we know the
biggest chinese day festival is the
chinese new year
and the chinese new year
you keep it as a sabbath
you know the first day you don't do
anything
the the chinese new year is just like
the jewish passover we have it
the passover of course is is
you can say it's a prophecy about the
coming messiah yes but celebrated in
this cultural way
and it's 14 days you know from day one
and to the 14th of the day they have the
pascal lamb and so forth hey chinese
have the same thing wow from day one of
the
noonan calendar of the first month to
the 15th
you celebrate the chinese new year
and during the first three days at least
the first day you don't cook
and the they have the firecrackers you
have the fireworks and so forth it is
that this day there is a big disaster is
coming
so you need
the celebration is this somehow that is
being
removed so we celebrate that disaster is
gone it's just like in the
uh
passover
the killing of the firstborn because of
the land
the jewish put blood over the doorpost
oh wow
the chinese put the red cabinet yeah
over the doorpost
so every year you celebrate the same
the even then the chinese quraniyan
literal translation is a passover it's
the same well the jews do that because
that's their history so i'm wondering
why the chinese do it because chinese
were exposed to the oral revelation
so they knew they have it to right from
the tower of babel do you have the
knowledge of god the revelation of god
they got it
the jewish
god called abraham trying to restore
what was lost yeah but that was not
jewish was not the first time god did it
yeah because
balaam was clearly a prophet to a people
that was not you know part of the hebrew
culture so
you know god was working with different
cultures all along the way and perhaps
that was you know
that was just a symbol that god chose
that the blood was going to be over the
door of your house you know
so that's why the
china's flag is red
the chinese color is red yeah and
because it's red it means blessing
even for weddings i mean wedding and you
have to be in red
and red
if you look at look at the back at least
we can see the blood but it's also
wedding is a covenant yes
and
today the virginity it doesn't mean much
today but however
in the bible
when the husband and wife are entering
in the covenant relationship
you need to see blood
because the blood is the thing that's
blessing seal the ceremony seal the
relationship
that is in the chinese culture and which
is
normally lost in the west you have no
clue i think it's so neat to hear the
historical reasoning why the color red
is is really i mean because i think red
when i when i think chinese but i had no
idea that there was these little like
ties into the bible yeah it is beautiful
but it's also
interesting and amazing that
all that is there and yet
how much of it understood how much of is
it is christian at this point
um
the the actual number is hard to know
but i would say
you know 5
we have about 80
million
80 million christians questions in china
at all but out of billions that's
probably it's still a small
fraction
but many people retain some concept here
and there yeah because i'm assuming it's
taught in schools right because this is
your history and it's
but then another thing is that uh satan
as we know is trying to
reverse everything that's that's
actually a point i want to i want to
touch on a little bit if you can because
it's like you're telling us all this
stuff but it
today you go and ask the average chinese
person it's they're probably not
thinking along these lines it doesn't
mean that to them
so another thing is
uh one of the creatures that's highly
revered in chinese culture is the dragon
but
the bible tells us the dragon is our
enemy so how did this get
turned around where it's like the dragon
is highly upheld and yet the dragon as a
as a biblical symbol is our enemy
very good question
uh the dragon
i have mentioned the three things the
tradition
and chinese
writings
and the chinese classics so in china we
don't have a bible but we have classics
the chinese classics is the one that is
authentic uh um
where bonafide is chinese culture joy
can come from the focal culture it was
developed much later so it's like fairy
tales
it was
it was never never was that it was
recorded in chinese classics it was not
there
the chinese actually we call ourselves
the ambassador of the truth ambassador
of doubt that's how we name ourselves
and uh another name for us is
the people of
the from the of the land of god shinzo
ernie so do you have any
conflicting like so you have folklo over
here and it talks about the dragon do
you have anything
in uh
in the literature yes that says the
opposite or speaks differently or names
the dragon as the enemy or talks about a
serpent
or something like that like the genesis
story the word actually appeared the
word dragon appeared in the first book
of
the book of changes which was another
interesting fact for you pepe
the bible was written by 40 authors over
1600 years
the book of changes was written over
2500 years by 87 authors
okay
and it's it's consistent
so don't tell me there's only one book
that was written over a long period of
time by different authors there was
another one 87 authors
2500 years in that book dragon was
mentioned
but it's not the concept as we
have culturally have today like you
you know you just your new new year you
play the dragon game and
dragon dance you don't have that in the
classics
and i can show you something uh
just to say what is in the classics i
show you
two uh
important the names people know one is
loud
one is confucius okay these two people
are
the contemporary of
daniel the prophet in the hebrew culture
okay about five or six hundred years
before christ
and in the old testament the book of
daniel have 12 chapters the catholic
bible has 14 chapters
and however
it is the shortest book
have the most complete description
prophecies about the mission
of the messiah
and repentance and remission of sin
like what daniel talks about yes and not
only that the 2300 days prophecy is
talking about you know the
the cut off the messiah and the six
missions of the messiah and uh it covers
all his life
everything
however at the same time in china at
this time i want to show
what these two sages in the chinese
history what they said
about uh the most important part in the
chinese culture now let's hear uh loudly
what he said
lars left a book
is about five thousand words
daniel has about ten thousand words so
laos is even
shortened yeah it has
i mentioned about the holy man 29 times
and
he talks about a lot about the holy man
but i would just bring one here
and he says he who
therefore said the holy man is not he's
talking about holy man he's the holy man
himself he's talking about his own
mission
he said he who is disgraced for the
kingdom is the lord of the kingdom
he who suffers for the kingdom is the
king of the universe wow
like isaiah
this is about just
600 years before christ was born
and what can you make out of that
you know
this is uh
uh let me just show you another one
which is what confucius is talking about
many people knows about confucius
uh the western um
scholarship i think they made a mistake
about confucianism
confucius was the founder of
confucianism which is not true
confucius was the compiler
of the writings at his time
so he compiled them together but he was
not the founder
today the scholarship i understand they
made a mistake so they are changing
confucianism into the name that we
chinese use like ruja
ruja is to make you soft
it's through
the silent influence
to change your stony heart to make you
soft that's that's basically rudya
and confucius had a lot of teachings
very good i would just mention one
this is a mystery to many scholars
because he said
if truly a king were to arise it would
still require 30 years for his love to
be
manifested wow
wow yeah
that's amazing
he was he was 500 years before christ
wow wow and there was a time in the
analytics
it was recorded
people come to ask him are you the holy
man
he said no i'm not then this guy is
asking
are you were the first three empress
which is a holy man he said no how about
the five kings no
and how about the three royal empress no
and then this man was very surprised
then he said
who who actually is this holy man
confucius was greatly removed and he
answered the holy man is in the west
and if you look at the map
look at
the map
where jesus was born to china it's west
of china so if you put all these chinese
descriptions about the holy man about
the holy king
and only one man said
you know who waited who was born as a
king waited for 30 years to publicly
demonstrate love
what i think is amazing about that is
like you know people always say well
isn't it going to be like uh you know a
lot of people who you know never got a
chance to choose god or whatever like
this this is like a evidence of god
mercifully
reaching out to many different cultures
and civilizations with a with a similar
similar um you know understanding of
what's really going on
i think the spiritual heritage from the
chinese
cannot only help the chinese or asians
but maybe it also can be helpful
to our uh western
people at least now you can see some
extra biblical evidence
which supports the bible good so here i
think it would be an interesting point
to touch on if you have anything on this
um
a lot of people say that the sabbath was
only a jewish concept
do you have anything in chinese
literature heritage that talks about the
sabbath oh of course
let me mention it again so that we make
it clear the bible was written
3500 years ago
the sabbath was recorded in genesis
chapter 2. sure oh that's only 3500
years ago the chinese have a book which
was older
by 500 years ago
which is the book of changes in this
book of changes in in the chapter 24
and it says
it says this friend comes without blame
two and the thrill goes away on the
seventh day comes this return
this is the course of heaven
now this is written 3 000 years ago 4
000 4 000. sorry 3 500 plus 500 yes 4
000. yeah this is probably the earliest
close to the second chapter of genesis
of of uh of the sabbath it didn't say
the sabbath but it says it comes to
return every seventh day returns
and this is not the movement of the son
of moon on earth but it's the course of
heaven heaven comes every second so in
your in your language like the
pictographic language
the word for sabbath is there a word for
sabbath or is it just
seventh day or how is it written and
described we have the two words one is a
man
resting against a tree
okay let's find a rest
and there's sabbas in the chinese the
ancient language it's
the tian shiu is heaven's rest
it's not human rest it heaven's rest
it's uh
and then we have another word
she is your your mind your spirit and
your
self
mind rest put to rest
put the rest of where i think if you put
these two together
you put it against the tree of life
that's where you find your rest
because hey just like the cell phone you
know
when it comes to twenty percent
ten percent
where can you wrestle yours your mind if
you find it charging yeah plug
recharge recharge it then you
be peaceful restful
and our life comes to our energy level
has come to ten percent five percent if
we can be connected with the tree of
life amen
then
we are finally
and that is depicted in the chinese word
and just in case people don't know that
it's about the sabbath this is how they
kept it
it says
something within the earth this is
and the image the king of the antiquity
closes the passes at the day of its
arrival
and the merchants and strangers didn't
go about and the ruler didn't travel
through the provinces this is how they
keep that day right so if that is not
the sabbath i don't know what that is
if the chinese have a four words uh
uh chi
rightful every seventh day come back
every time every single day it's a it's
an idiom in the chinese okay so we do
have a chinese now the chinese calendar
is seven days at now right but was there
a time in history that they tried to
change that because i've heard always
kind of people's argument with like oh
the calendar's never always been seven
days the chinese made it 10 at one point
no the chinese have been keeping this
seventh day
yeah but what they did in the 1911
sabbath before you entered that is
sabbath the seventh day in the chinese
state yeah okay and the the in 1911 the
adopted solar system
so like calendar but before that we
always have only one calendar which is
nunan calendar
but within the lunar economy still the
seventh day
and
maybe i can tell you one more
interesting incident in 1986 there was
a new science was founded in america
it's called
chronobiology okay because he they
discovered the seven days ribbon in the
human body really so the
the professor who who was the inventor
or discover of this
new decimal came to china
to share his discovery so we found the
seven days written in the human body now
we have the new science
bio chronology
audi finished
he came to the chinese university of
traditional chinese medicine
so one professor there stood up said sir
i'm sorry to tell you
what you have discovered we had it
recorded in our medical books
four thousand years ago the latest it
would be eighteen hundred years ago
nothing new here
nothing new seven days rhythm in the
human body
not only recorded in the book of changes
as i showed you but also recorded in the
medical book wow
wow so so to say the sabbath is only for
the jews i think you you got to visit
china and find out yeah it's not only
for the jews
it's meant for the chinese man of
everyone interesting i mean it's really
amazing because there was a film that
came out years ago called zeitgeist that
they basically tried to
disprove christianity by showing all of
these other cultures that had these
similar
you know stories and parallels and
things like that right but they were
using that as an argument to say see
christianity just stole it from this but
it's really truly amazing to see and
hear
that these things have you know it's
like almost confirmation that those
things that were told to us in the
hebrew bible is is true from god
now for those who are interested in
seeing the historical documentation i
have a book called god and the ancient
chinese cool this is a
you have all the historical documents
documentation at the back has appendix
so
nothing made up and it was all there
that is because the chinese were exposed
to the oral revelation so they tell the
exactly the same like what the bible
teaches this is a book you wrote yes did
you bring one
i did it
where can we find out can we can we give
one away on the show i looked on amazon
those were interested call 1 800
245 1844 and you can order a book from
number yeah and how much is the book
i don't know maybe because on amazon
it's 596 dollars
wow yeah i think it's about 20. about
20. yeah okay i would guess yeah yeah
100 245 1844. okay okay thank you 245
very cool we'll put the link in the
description below and and so people can
find that didn't end the number with
eight i know that's what i was saying
but this is the american number
let me just bring you to the bible in
isaiah 49 verse 12 it says behold this
shall come from far
and low this from the north and from the
west and this from the land of sinner
now you would wonder what land is that
and
so
if you look at
today the linguistic route
if you want to say china u.s relations
what would you say
say sino u.s relations
that's right yeah and if you do
if you check out the youngest
concordance or
strong's concordance
it's all referring to a
foreign land maybe china
and
the issue is here is when isaiah wrote
about this
he was he was writing this 500 years
before the names
qin which is the one here cinema to
come into existence so in a way it was a
prophecy that dynasty was the one who
turned against god turned away from
against god
but was short-lived only 14 years
so we call ourselves higher
hans we call for ourselves and we
identified ourselves with the next
dynasty
not with this one but this is the one
that all the foreign language call us
we call call us chinese
so the bible is giving a promises saying
there will be people
coming from the north from the west and
also coming from the land of china to
worship god it's a beautiful promise in
the chinese
ourselves we call jungkook
the word god means kingdom country
zhong means
uh
no deviation
from the will of heaven
this is the people this is a country
that
follows the the mandate of heaven
without
any slightest division that is the
meaning of china so yeah the chinese
followers of godzilla they're followers
of the word of god yeah beautiful that
is how we call ourselves we call
ourselves
we don't call up some chinese and that's
widespread across china or just bible
that is known as is known in the chinese
chinese i mean that's even more amazing
to me when you think about china outline
christianity
you know what i mean like the whole
country like it's like it has such deep
connections and roots to god
i mean the name and everything i had no
idea that that was the case so how we
can call
uh you know because we call you know
chinese so we don't call we can call it
oh it's okay because
for better communication this is the way
oh okay how you doing i've embraced it
how you do it and it doesn't matter
anymore but however in the chinese in
the chinese that is the way
we we call ourselves so the word china
means
no deviation yeah
yeah learn something new every day oh
yeah so many revelations
you know god never left himself without
witnessing
what it says
so
when the whole world
you know is turning around and we we're
now trying to find scientific evidences
come on when you find one there's
another one battling it okay
you know so okay this is one of those uh
i'm not sure about it yeah hey here is
the one you cannot you cannot argue
this is the evidence from the chinese
you cannot argue from the writings from
the classics even from the traditions so
historical site the worship of heaven
all of these are there how can you argue
to say
the chinese didn't know god and they
never worshipped god it's all there and
not only that they are the same with the
bible of god the creator god that's the
one we worship yeah so sharing the
gospel sometimes we're thinking oh no
technology is going to be rich in china
they're in their own scripture you know
it's already this is already there yeah
so that is for today i think the meaning
for me is that that is something we can
use to build bridges absolutely we we
have because many of those cards are
lost but you have a bible
everything what god want us to know is
here it's true it's complete
and whatever is essential for us is all
here so how do we bring people to the
bible you know you when you sometimes
need to build some bridges
exactly yeah i love the way you put that
you're building a bridge
that's that's exactly what we need to do
and it's amazing how god has you know
he's reaching out to so many people in
so many different times and so many
different places and you're just like i
love you i want to save you this is my
plan like and it's revealed itself in
our
in your very language
you know it's incredible
so so if people want to like know more
where can they
find do you have a youtube channel and i
do have a youtube channel about uh i
have a documentary about the six eight
programs
it's showing our ancestor the god
worshiping tradition
unfortunately in chinese but with
english subtitles okay english sometimes
it's called usually it's the other way
around
the ambassador of the dao the dao in the
chinese
the dollar is a god the dollar is
creator the dollar is the savior the dow
is the way the doubt is the truth that
is the life the doubt the judgment
the dao is a word or for everything the
dao is god incarnated
so
the chinese is considered to be the
ambassador of that dao the only close
one is
in heaven
in english
and that could be referred to but that's
a chinese sound dao that is our name for
god
and uh there is a youtube uh channel for
that i don't come
yeah we'll put the link
yes exactly well dr
uh wang is that how you say it dr wang
it's okay
i butchered it sorry
dr wong thank you so much for being on
our show and educating and sharing all
this information with us it's
really fascinating and
i'm sure there's much more that we could
learn in his book so we'll have the
phone number
and all that information for you guys in
the description below if you want to
look into this more
and
we thank you guys for joining us and
you know take some time and reflect on
this think about how god is trying to
reach you and and take a look at this
extra biblical evidence you know it's
easy to
maybe look at westernized christianity
and discount some of the things in it
but here we have some clear evidence
from the east for the very things that
we're reading out reading in the bible
some of them are even older than what we
have written in western society so take
a look at that we encourage you and
share with somebody who might need to
hear this
and we will see you guys on another
episode of led live in the future thank
you for joining us
[Music]
[Applause]
so
[Music]
you